albert breer of sports illustrated
joining us here on the rich eisen show
uh here in a very crazy time in the nfl
how are you albert
i feel like we got hosed here because
we're playing the fake cinderella it's
never good to be playing the fake
cinderella fake cinderella
for a lot of years as a fake cinderella
where they're actually a tough team yes
but it looks bad if you lose to them you
know what i mean
i do appreciate that yes i do appreciate
that well i may not be rooting for your
school but i'm i'm rooting for you uh
albert since i know uh it's a uh a big
time basketball uh world there at ohio
state so
i'm rooting for you i'm really oh so
guys we are what like nine months left
is that right
i love it left
uh yes right around there uh
approximately eight or so so um what's
the scoop right now with baker mayfield
what's going on in in ohio in cleveland
yeah right now um you know i i think
like right now um you know it's just
it's i think they're sort of going to
wait for the rest of the quarterback
market to play out
and
you know just the same way a lot of
things were on hold
um when aaron rodgers was making his
decision
sort of feels the same way with deshaun
watson that he's sort of the last big
shoe to drop on the quarterback market
and then
you know you start to see the movement
does it mean matt ryan's gonna move um
obviously jimmy garoppolo the niners
have been waiting for the
the sean shoe to drop um
so they can get a little bit more
aggressive about potentially moving
jimmy um you know and i think bigger
sort of part of that equation
and the interesting thing about it you
know they did say um to baker that they
weren't going to honor his trade request
but really right now rich um they don't
have to say anything because if there's
a team that's interested nothing stops
that team from calling the browns and
inquiring just
having the i guess back and forth out
there essentially will smoke out you
know who's really interested in baker
and you know i think in the meantime
um you know they have to assess whether
or not going forward with baker is
manageable
and uh it wasn't the best option um
because i you know i think we all know
baker's history and
you know how he's reacted in the past to
people not believing him in them has
actually been you know relatively
favorable you go back you look at texas
tech in oklahoma um so it could mean the
browns get a really good season out of
them um the other question again is
going to be whether or not the
relationship's manageable and i think
the browns are going to take a little
bit of time here to figure that out well
i mean the the mike thompson phrase uh
this past year i think it involved
melvin ingram right where he said we
want
volunteers not hostages and it's uh i
think baker with his
costanza like i'm breaking up with you
before you break up with me note to
cleveland
um
and his reaction to say uh when the
browns reach out uh i want to trade i i
think he's declared he's going to be a
hostage if he sticks around right
right you know i mean
it's in the immediate aftermath and um i
love the reference there because that
that post the other night was definitely
dripping with passive aggression i would
say um
and yeah i mean i think right now he's
up that mind that he wants to go play
somewhere else
um what are his options that's the other
question no
would carolina trade for him
after they just failed a similar
experiment with sam darnold i don't know
um you know would
um indianapolis trade for him um you
know having gone to what they went
toward the quarterback position
that's what's fascinating about it rich
is like
you know like i just you know think or
walk out it's like where are you going
to are you going to have a chance to
start somewhere else and i'm sure he
wants to explore that
um but right now i don't think it's
impossible to look at it and not think
there's a scenario at the end of this
where the two sides may need each other
you know and where baker may not be able
to find a place where he's a clear-cut
starter elsewhere
maybe he will uh but there's a
possibility he doesn't and the browns
may look around and say
maybe we don't have a better option
right now than that basically
so then what what is the before we move
on here what is the back story
you know in the similar way that seattle
you you hear for anybody talks about
seattle and russell wilson it was just
time to move on like that's and which is
the shorthand of they were sick of him
and he was sick of them and the question
is what made them sick over each other
and and it's kind of
we're in that situation right here like
so what what is the
the issue
did it involve odell is it the coach's
scheme and the is in efficiency in
running it
is it the way he's acting behind the
scenes like what is it what is that
there are some leaders and questions um
and i think it's
it's not bigger than trying to be a
leader i think he is um you know but the
sense i've gotten
is you know there were times where he
would get after teammates and there was
questions i think in the locker room
whether or not he'd earn the right to do
that you know and
so you know i mean for example say
a receiver runs the wrong route in
practice say
an offensive lineman um doesn't get a
protection call right whatever it is
baker might get after that guy and then
that guy might look sideways and stand
for you to call me out on this one you
missed x y and z over here you know and
so i think there was a little bit of
that cause and friction for baker
i don't know if it's the root of the
odell thing but i think it existed
um
and you know i i think that there's that
question too that sort of
um you know i think exists for the
browns and it's something that browns
are going to have to confront which is
you know after all this
is he still going to have i guess like
the leadership capital in the locker
room are they going to be able to lean
on him to be the guy
in 2022 with the team that they
rightfully believe
is really really good like has a chance
to be really really good and be right
back in the playoffs after injuries and
you know some of those other things
derailed them last year
albert brewer here on the rich eisen
show so uh in your mailbag today on
sports illustrated the mmqb um you
mentioned that the
issue with watson and deciding to either
go home in atlanta um to atlanta where
the weapons wouldn't be the same as new
orleans or go to new orleans and just
start
uh fresh there uh money is now entering
the equation is that the hold up while
we're we're not seeing anything or part
of the reason why teams have dropped out
or been told they're not
winning these sweepstakes i think it's a
factor you know i've heard new money
i've heard guaranteed money
has been part of the equation there and
you know i
i really at this point like get the
sense that like he really
i think he's intrigued by the idea of
going home you know and i think he's
sort of there's a part a huge part of
him that wants to go to atlanta while
realizing that the best football
situation in 2022 like
is in new orleans and so nobody
everything factors in
and i mean look like i mean if we're
being you know honest about this like he
and his people probably have to pray for
a suspension doesn't mean it's going to
happen but the possibility is that it
happens you've got a 35 million dollar
base um for next year so i mean like a
like a half season suspension right like
if he's suspended for eight games
like what would that be i mean
like i don't know rich i went to ohio
state so i'm not great at math but i
would say uh i mean that's like what
like 16 million dollars possible he can
lose so he might ask the team
to move money around and then guarantee
money down the line to protect himself
against being suspended this year you
know and so i think all of that is part
of the equation you know and i i think
you know part of it for him is probably
wanting to know
you know the team's all in on him and is
going to stick by him in the case of a
suspension and that sort of thing and
i'd say like the drastic compensation
going the other way is probably pretty
good proof of that for whoever acquires
him um yeah but i do think the contract
is you know
at least a piece of the puzzle
and if this thing is really close
between atlanta and new orleans and i
think it is and that's why it's taking
so long
um you know then
the contract could end up being sort of
some sort of tiebreaker well i mean if
the contract and the money and the
compensation is tied to how the the rest
of watson's civil suits play out how
come we're not talking more about the
civil suit situation it's it's almost as
if well the no bill comes in criminally
all good now let's all rush to go get
deshaun watson and there's no question
about
how this is all going to play out or or
or
no i mean
i mean i think there is a question and i
mean look like
this is part of the reason i mean i can
tell you
on wednesday night uh the gail benson
the saints owner she flew to atlanta to
meet with them to sit down and meet with
them and i think that that's sort of
symbolic of what this is for every team
that was involved which is it takes
ownership sign off like ownership i
guess technically has to sign off on any
big move but you and i both know like a
lot of those are rubber stamps this
isn't a rubber stamp you know what i
mean like this is
like the guy's gonna be the face of your
franchise and so his problems become
your problems and this isn't even i mean
i've heard the comparison of mike bick
but that's different too
because mike vick was coming into
philadelphia as a third string guy
you're not requiring sean watson to be
the third guy
you know accounting watson he's the most
i mean notable person in your franchise
from the minute that he walks in the
door
and so yeah i would say it's very much a
piece of equation um
because it um and i think i've said this
to you a few times but several you know
several teams have had their security
people on this for over a year and those
are all excellent law enforcement people
who are able to get information
you know and then a couple of these
teams have had private investigators on
the ground in houston i'm not sure
atlanta is one of those because they
were late comers to the party right so
maybe they've been playing catch up a
little bit on this but
um but there are teams that were
involved that were comfortable after
doing that amount of homework so again
i'm not saying
anybody's not taking this seriously i
think every team is involved is
um you know but certainly i think you
know
uh with the with the 22 civil suits out
there
you know there's there's
there's a level of risk that comes with
it and there's
um you know uh i would say
you know you hate to even call it a pr
hit but like that's sort of what it is
like that that you are going to
take on certain things that are that are
going to come along with acquiring
deshaun watson regardless of what city
it's in
all right before i let you go albert the
biggest story i'm in my mind
of of this non-playing season right now
um has to be rogers stays adams goes i
mean what an oh henry-like plot twist
to the way the packers are trying to
continue to run it back
um how did this come about and how do
you think it sits with aaron rodgers so
many people just assume
he's got to be livid with the packers
organization but the packers uh read
them into it from all i hear yeah right
yeah yeah and and i think
that's such a key thing because like the
communication last year rich was nowhere
i mean i
i can tell you like i think there was
like a six week two month period
whatever it was last year where the
packers literally couldn't get a hold of
him um and you know i think he's been
pretty public in saying like he wants to
be in the loop on these sorts of things
um and so you know like the fact that
the packers kept him in the loop
throughout i think softens the blow here
i also think he's so close to devonte
adams
that he probably understands his
reasons for doing this and for wanting
out probably better than even the team
does you know and so
if this really was unworkable
and the packers really were willing to
go financially where adams went with the
raiders
and
it was still you know at this point
where there was nothing the packers
could do
then i think aaron rodgers probably has
a pretty good understanding of it
obviously he wants great players around
him and davonte adams is a great great
player maybe the best receiver in
football
um but you know i think the fact that
you know he was
i think a prize of this and the
communication is so much better than it
was a year ago softens the blow i think
that that i i would have to think and i
don't know this for a fact but i would
have to think that there is a plan b
that's been communicated to aaron
rodgers for how they're going to handle
this now going forward and maybe it
means taking a big swing at receiver
whether it's signing in odell beckham or
trading up for robert woods or whatever
it is trading for dk metcalf whatever it
is out there um i i'd assume that
there's been some sort of plan that's
been communicated in rajas where he
feels comfortable because of course i
think by now we would have heard that
there was a huge issue on his end
trading for dk metcalf you think that's
possible
i mean i think it sort of depends so
seattle to me is interesting just
because i mean dk metcalf is going to be
expensive to keep it's going into a
contract here
and
you know i think it's it's one of those
where it's like
if they
say like they're going forward with drew
lock at quarterback right and they make
the decision we're turning the page
right
and i'm sure you know like they'll have
an idea you know by the time we get to
the draft of whether or not dk is going
to be on the team pass this year
so like it's one of those where it's
like if this is a retooling year
is it i mean if you and you know you're
not going to be able to resign them
or you know you're just that far apart
in contract negotiations it may make
sense again if this is a year where
you're restocking the cupboard and
trying to you know turn around and draft
well and kind of build a new base for
yourself it could make sense where you
know dk metcalf's you know value right
now would be at a high point so it's a
call i'm not saying they're i'm not
saying they're they are are going to
shop him
but you know if you're a team like the
packers i think it's a call that you
make certainly if you've got the draft
capital now because adam's left and
right the question i have last one for
you is why was it unworkable for adams
if they did put the money on the table
was it is from what it appears just too
late like they should have done it last
year that's it yeah i think that's
really it you know i think he had it in
his head i don't know if you guys saw
the reports out there uh from a couple
weeks ago that he built he bought like a
um a 12 million dollar mansion i think
it was in vegas and i'm not like that up
on vegas real estate but i think 12
million bucks goes a long way
in las vegas right
in buying a house so it comes with the
blue it comes with the blue man group i
think yeah
something that big but i i i'd assume
i'd assume that there was uh i i you
know there are enough breadcrumbs here
where
it does seem like you know i like
devante had it in his head that you know
my college teammates there it's a team i
grew up rooting for it's a team i've
dreamed of playing for and oh by the way
like now i find out that they're willing
to satisfy every financial desire that i
have
um you know i i like i think he's just
kind of that maybe that thought deak in
uh devante's headache gone to the point
of no return and
i mean it's a great sign for the for the
i mean i'll throw this in there too but
just to finish up rich uh you look at
josh mcdaniels and what he's doing in
vegas and how opposite it is of what
they did in denver where he immediately
saddles up to the quarterback and
partners with the quarterback and has
been so effusive on derek carr
and now instead of tearing the team down
and bringing in middling pieces the way
they did in denver
um you know they're going and they're
going big game hunting and bringing in
chandler jones and devonte adams i could
see why that would be attractive to
somebody like adam yeah man all right
the afc west huh isn't that it it's just
oh yeah
who who would have thought three weeks
ago if i told you three weeks ago the
chiefs are going to be the least
aggressive team in the afc west how
would you respond
it would have been surprising but also
somewhat understanding that you you got
to go for it i mean honestly yeah look
at the afc west right now uh you've got
if i had to ask you name me the top five
pass catchers in the league i think
you'd say adams hill and kelsey would be
would be in three of them right if
you're gonna you gotta name me some of
the top uh quarterbacks in the nfl you
you'd definitely go with mahomes and
herbert would be thrown in there right
and
now russ is there and then now you got
to get past rushers to prevent all these
guys which is i mean you look at the
pass rushers it's insane chandler jones
max crosby bradley chubb now randy
gregory coming over
um you know frank clark i know he didn't
have a great year last year but they
hope he'll bounce back and then boston
in la is pretty crazy it's great albert
thanks for the time have a great weekend
i hear the kids in the background i
appreciate you uh tapping out to do that
ohio state by five at the half
in case you're wondering the update i
did walk away from it so i appreciate it
yeah up by five at the half thanks for
the call robert appreciate it hopefully
we hopefully we can take to take down
the fake cinderella for for all the
people
well again it's not just big ten it's
for the basketball school in columbus
so i appreciate that it'll be great
eight months well it's a if it would be
a longer eight months if you can't hold
on to this five-game five-point lead
last time we spoke my team was blowing
it against indiana that just got blown
out by saint mary's and i'm sitting
pretty i'm sitting in that second uh
spot you know we're okay now though
yesterday take care of yourself albert
be well rich that's albert right here on
the rich eisen show hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here